over these past couple of months our
foundation has been shaken not just by a
pandemic that stole too many of our
loved ones up ended our daily lives and
sent tens of millions in the
unemployment but also by the rumbling of
the age-old fault lines that our country
was built on the lines of race and power
that are now once again so nakedly
exposed for all of us to grapple with
Michelle Obama addressing the Cova 19
pandemic and police brutality protests
during YouTube's graduation special if
any of you are scared or confused or
angry or just plain overwhelmed by it
all if you feel like you're searching
for a lifeline just to steady yourself
you are not alone I am feeling all of
that too
I think we all are the former first lady
brought up all sorts of important
questions if you require to work during
a pandemic but don't have enough
protective equipment or health insurance
from your employer or paid sick leave
well what is more essential your work or
your life if you don't feel safe driving
your own car in your own neighborhood or
going for a jog or buying some candy at
7-eleven or bird-watching if you can't
even approach the police without fearing
for your life well then how do you begin
to chart your own course she also had
some answers and offered words of hope
you're spending a lot of time just hash
tagging and posting right now that's
useful especially during a pandemic but
it's only a beginning go further send
all your friends a link to register to
vote texted everybody you know to join
you in exercising their constitutional
right to protest that makes it even more
important for us as a nation to
and that's one of the reasons why we
want to be that voice because we can
garner some attention I know you can do
it because over these many years I've
seen exactly who you are
I've seen your creativity and your
talent and your resourcefulness
graduates you all are exactly what we
need right now and for the years and
decades to come do you get here because
you work hard and a lot of kids don't
know that because they're living with
that doubt in their heads Barak also had
an inspiring message to share and we
want you to know that all the work
you've put in to get your education is
still one of the best investments you
can make we've seen it for decades the
more education you have the better you
and your families are likely to fare
it's been borne out over the past couple
of months and it will be the case for
years to come so you all have done
something great hold your heads high and
celebrate with all the important
messages the pair said they also
encouraged graduates to celebrate and go
ahead and do a little dance cool dance
maybe even not so cool if you're just by
yourself but the important thing is to
celebrate congratulations again
everybody and now we hope you enjoyed
the rest of this once-in-a-lifetime
commencement gotta be good it's gonna be
great
[Music]